hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna do some styling on our react
native web app so just as a quick intro
this show is just about me
coding live it's not rehearsed so I will
make mistakes it's it's not exactly a
tutorial so there definitely may be
better ways to do what I'm trying to do
I set a Pomodoro timer and we code for
25 minutes and then I take a little
break and answer some questions in the
live chat and we'll do that probably
twice and I'll be live live coding and
answering questions for about an hour
today feel free to ask questions about
anything you want I'll do my best to
answer all the questions and I
definitely encourage contributions so if
you have ideas for the project you know
go ahead and put those in the live chat
as well so if you check the description
to this video you can find a link to the
github repo where you can see all the
code that I'm using here so far
everything is pretty much in a pas we
haven't broken anything else out into
separate components yet although we we
probably will soon and let's see it
whoops gotta start it so we built this
out using treat react app but we're also
using react native web and that means
we're going to be using react native
syntax but it is rendering to the Dom
instead of Android or iOS alright let's
start up the timer
okay this is the github repo and I guess
I'll throw this link in the chat as well
just in case so I have a few you saying
hi hey hey how's it going
alright so here's what we have so far it
doesn't look great so let me tell you
what I'm thinking in terms of styling
and then I'll get some feedback and
we'll go from there so right off the bat
I say since the auto target audience is
children I'll probably approach the
styling through this a little bit
different than I normally would for for
an app we want to keep the inputs and
the fonts larger than normal see
probably keep the colors like pretty
bright okay and other than that just
like anything like play any playful
elements we could add will probably be
be good as well
so let's let's think about these
characters so right now this is supposed
to be like the hero character and these
are the enemies so I'm thinking maybe we
could use some CSS to style these I
don't know I'll go back and forth so
like my ideas are either like we could
try to find like some like sprites to
use right like video game sprites right
and have like characters that look like
real characters or we could keep it
autumn or look just like normal divs and
just do some styling on it to make them
look
different so there's some pretty cool
stuff you can do with your CSS I'll let
y'all think about that for a minute and
let me know in the chat which you think
like should we try to find you know
images to use for for our characters or
should we see if we can do some some CSS
stuff so I'm I genuinely am just not
sure at this point what I what I'd
rather do you know I imagine the CSS
stuff has the advantage of the the
overall game being smaller in terms of
file size but I don't know that it'll be
that big of a difference also some some
other ideas I had for styling is that
depending on the game mode the colors
could change right potentially like the
enemies could change right so the
addition enemies would be different than
the subtraction enemies right different
colors at least maybe maybe different
background right I'm not right now it's
very bright it's very bright and white
so we could definitely go with a
different background okay all right I'm
gonna go to the chat really quick and
just see what you all think about about
whether to go with images or just some
some cool CSS stuff Jake knife says
definitely use images Vincent says yes
you sprites Sergei says SVG actually
yeah if we could find some SVG's that
that would be really cool
Mohammed says CSS can be better you have
more control over it that's true if if
we could find SVG's some like SVG images
we could for maybe have the best of both
worlds where we could still use CSS to
manipulate the images and have control
like potentially we could change colors
programmatically okay
Vincent says so why not you sprites yeah
I'm open I'm open to that okay so my
next question would be does anybody know
where a good place to get sprites are
like right now I'd probably be looking
for some free stuff but I'm I'm not
opposed to like paying for for good
stuff I mean you know maybe some cool
backgrounds too might not be a bad idea
so I just don't know where the best
place to get that is so if anybody has
any ideas put them in the chat if you
want to paste a link it probably won't
show up but I'll still be able to see it
just know what else we'll be able to see
it so I'm not gonna take time to let go
search for sprites right now because
before I be boring to just watch me do
Google searches so let's try to work on
some of the other styles for now so I
imagine let's see in web app mode
positioning is not a huge deal but on
different screen sizes we're probably
going to run into some issues so you do
need to consider that
might want to maybe just like decrease
the size of these at some point but
probably wait until we figure out
whether we're using sprites or not to
actually do that so let's check it let's
look at maybe some some color schemes
and we need to make if I want things to
change you probably need to set up a
theme so let's go ahead and do that now
and just set up a like a CSS theme that
can be easily changed based on state
okay so currently since the entire app
is just in this one app dot J's file
this is going to be pretty easy to set
up a theme eventually we will have to
probably pass down some things but I
think it should still be okay sorry
yawning again I think I'm actually
getting sick I have my throat really
hurt so I might be a little bit more
tired and slow today
so do we have CSS yet I can't remember
if we did it yeah we do okay cool
so we do have oh yeah we have some
styles in here we have some colors what
I want to do
based on our state is is switch that out
so okay the themes are going to need
maybe we should just base the themes off
of like the addition theme the
subtraction theme that I think that kind
of makes that makes sense right so if
we're gonna do it like that then we
could just use mode so we don't really
need a different thing in state right so
for now let's just set some background
colors on the main container div and
then it'll be really obvious just to
test things out it's probably not gonna
look really good right now
but it'll be a good really good test
okay so for our Styles let's say we're
gonna have styles equal so we'll have
styles equals or styles dot root but
we're gonna do two styles so when we
want to add more than one style we're
gonna just make a an array inside this
this object right and then we can just
separate everything with commas just
like a normal array so we could also do
styles and then I'm gonna do instead of
the normal dot syntax right I'm gonna do
let's start or I'm gonna put a variable
in here it's right so I don't want to
put dot so I'm gonna put this state mode
and actually while we're at it let's
let's do some destructuring so you don't
have to use this state everywhere right
so if you're not familiar with
destructuring here's what we're gonna do
so we're gonna say cost
and we're gonna put in some of the
elements of upstate so we're gonna do
mode let's see what else we have here
let's just put all of our state I'm just
gonna copy this for now and paste it
down here just so that I can see it and
then we'll just get rid of it so let's
do mode answer number of enemies though
one vow to one and operator okay if this
doesn't make sense right now will it
will in a second and then we're gonna
say equals this dot state okay so now
that we have all of these here every
place where we say this dot State down
below we can get rid of so it's it's
gonna clean things up a little bit so
I'm just going to use the multiple
cursors here there we go and get rid of
them all so now we don't have to keep
typing the state and it definitely
cleans things up a bit
selected value language uh uh did I
forget
hmm
was that really this state
you know what this was probably left
over from the example I copied and
pasted and I just never never did
anything so selected value for this
picker is always gonna equal the mode
and alright so let's save it and just go
go over just to show that you know
everything still works so subtraction
multiplication division also looks like
our our selector here our picker is not
wide enough so we need to change the the
width of that okay but other than that
everything's still still working there
we go yeah still working okay
now what will happen is we can have
styles for each mode and we'll put that
down here right so we can have addition
and let's just say background color and
we're gonna make them just super obvious
for now background color green and we'll
just copy this for each one and change
it up subtraction
subjection multiplication and division
pink yellow and orange I'm trying to
pick different colors then we already
have on the screen for other things okay
let's see if that worked ha ha
Oh actually with multiplication doesn't
work yellow
don't tell me i misspelled this I'm you
know it's vacation I'm gonna copy and
paste this so that I don't even have to
worry about spelling that's
multiplication there we go there must
have been a misspelling and division
that orange does not really look orange
that's kind of weird maybe it's just my
screen maybe it looks different for you
I think it's my screen because on my
other screen I can see it and it looks
way more orange on my other screen
alright okay so this is not like the
prettiest thing in the world right now
but at least we can see like how it how
it could work here okay now I did think
while I was doing that I thought
actually this may not be the best way to
do it because I can pretty much only
change the background here right so what
I could do I could actually make
separate style sheets right so instead
of just having caught styles we could
have like we could have our regular
constant styles right and then I could
also have Const for addition style
subtraction styles right and then up
here so I'm trying to find where we have
this up here instead of styles dot root
style stop mode it would be like styles
that route but then we could have
addition styles or whatever dot root and
this would be the thing what would
change is the name
the basically the mode right so I think
that's a better way to go because then
we could have styles for a lot of other
stuff right for our our heroes and our
enemies right so I think that's a better
way to go let me check my time see if
you have enough time to get to do that
yeah we have about seven minutes so
it's just checking the chat really quick
to see if I done anything really crazy
okay so let's do that let's let me first
just copy everything here we're not
gonna change every single style here but
for now
actually before I copy everything four
times let me copy you one time then make
the adjustments and then copy that one
so we don't have to keep making
adjustments so our inputs is unlikely to
change so let's take that out for now
our text size is unlikely to change same
way with this just row container we're
gonna keep our here an enemy in there
because those will probably change our
container will be the same our
battlefield I'm gonna take that out for
now but you know we may want to actually
have some sort of like more intricate
battlefield background right and then
for this we're no longer going to need
addition subtraction multiplication down
here what we'll have then is just a
background color all right on route and
the here we would say addition
right alright so let's just take that
out and now I'll just copy this one and
let's change this to subtraction and
give this the background color
and this is going to be multiplication
which I'm definitely gonna copy and
paste since evidently I can't spell that
consistently and we're gonna give it
that yellow background these are likely
going to change at some point but it'll
give us a nice visual indicator at least
for now and one more
and that's division
the vision and it's orange
and
okay I think it's probably complaining
that we haven't actually used these
houses define attraction actually that's
really weird
did I copy Styles again a copy too many
times yeah I did okay let me get rid of
that one okay let's see if this will
work I know my my linter is not going to
like that I'm not using those but let's
see if this works
so we're gonna switch this up so it'll
say actually can I even do this I don't
know if anybody caught that this might
not work
rabbit workshops why am i copying so
much code just to change the background
color well kids where we're gonna change
more than the background color so I just
copied it to save us some typing later
but essentially like all those elements
I copied will change all of them but now
that I did this now I'm not sure it'll
work because
it's gonna be mode yeah this is not
gonna work all right I'll just try it
but I'm pretty sure this isn't gonna
work
yep it's not gonna work
oops well I have a syntax error - so
it's definitely not gonna work
all right yeah
all right how can I do this all right so
if you don't realize what I just did
that that was I really wish I would have
thought of before I just did all this
other stuff
I switched around so that basically the
variable part would be here but that's
that does not work you can't do that so
hmm I was trying to make it so that it
would work for multiple things all right
let me timers up so let me set this let
me go to the to the chat here and we'll
have to rethink I guess how we want to
do this theme let's see I just saw
Michael creo says can you do a switch
yeah I'm wondering if I'm wondering if
we may end up doing some sort of switch
alright let me scroll up so I can catch
as many questions that I can during this
this five-minute time period here let's
see a AEG says which language you use
JavaScript's mostly it looks like some
some other people have the same
questions
rjs how are you I'm doing all right I
think I'm getting sick but it's I don't
think it's serious thing it would just
be like a cold or something like that
Willie says hi there for coating being
this advanced is it too late for me to
start oh no no it's definitely not too
late for you to start I'm not sure if
you mean like to start following this
dream in which case I'd say no it's not
too late or like just to start learning
to code like in general either way it's
not too late John Paul says think crazy
ideas cool I'll try we have a question
I'm not try to pronounce your name so
sorry but the question is will web dev
die out I don't think it will die out it
it honestly seems like people are doing
more things on the web than they ever
have done right there are more
complicated applications now for the web
than at any point so and think about the
companies that are the biggest companies
in the world are companies who do things
on the web right
Facebook Google Amazon those are all
web-based companies and their their
revenue comes through the web so I do
not think web dev will die out anytime
soon in fact I don't know if you all saw
the announcement from Google about
stadia but Google's has this big gaming
thing now that's basically running
through a web browser so I know that's
like not exactly web dev but you know
that the platform is the web
Willie says I was thinking about
starting with html5 CSS JavaScript Java
and then some app coding and maybe games
well yeah definitely start out with your
HTML CSS JavaScript and then you'll be
able to do a ton of stuff with just that
and you probably have a good idea about
like what what you want to do you know
after that
let's see Mohammed asked what am I doing
here
oh I'm building a math game for kids so
just something really simple right now
we're just into like single digit math
Francis says this is quite impressive
but I'm still a beginner will I catch up
along the way yeah yeah you can catch up
and and if you always if you want to you
can check out the previous recordings
rabbit work says for the styling that we
were just doing put it in an array and
object for the color let's see
Jason Lima says what is there other than
the web I think this is in regard to the
you know will web dev die out so what is
there other than web mobile desktop yeah
I would say like that's it mobile and
desktop you could say like in terms of
programming like console gaming that's
programming Internet of Things so I mean
it's you could break it down but so many
things are tied into the web now it's
the lines between different types of
development I I think are getting really
blurred because it seems like everything
at some point ties into the web so maybe
like traditional web dev of like hey I
know HTML CSS I can do web development
that that is probably already dying
you're dead right all most successful
websites web apps need more than that
but web dev is now it's become more than
it was it we have more capabilities on
the web than we've had before so web dev
is not gonna die it's just it just
adapts and takes on more capabilities
all right let me let me take a note of
where we are in the chat and so I can go
back to it and I'm gonna restart my
Pomodoro timer and let's try to do more
okay so where we ended with our coding
was I just broke it so what I did let me
talk through what I did and what I was
trying to do and let's see if we could
figure out an answer here so what I
would like to do is have completely
different themes depending on the states
so we're gonna go off of this mode okay
so the mode will switch between addition
subtraction multiplication and division
and then based on that I've created
different themes down here or at least
started two for each one of those for
the addition subtraction multiplication
division right and these are Styles you
see these are essentially JavaScript
objects so what I need to do then is
switch them out however what I had hoped
I could do and then realize I couldn't
do was basically make this first part
here so we're using you know JavaScript
object and here it works because I could
say style start root so Styles is an
object but here what I'm trying to do is
use the value of mode as the object so
so mode itself is a string but what I
wanted to refer to is the name of
I wonder
hmmm alright so what I need is some way
and we can totally rethink everything
but like at this point I need some way
to designate which style sheet I want to
use here so we're gonna keep styles
always that'll be like our base styles
and then we'll cut down these themes to
be as like small as possible and only
change what what needs to be changed but
I need some way to put that in there so
let me see
Michel Creole says put it in the
existing switch or object literal okay
yeah alright let's take a look at that
switch statement to see what we could do
there alright so right now we are
since
you know what how do I do this I did a
theme so I could toggle a theme on a
project recently let me open it on my
other computer really quick and so I
already have it open on my other
computer so let me just check it
so let's see I in my other project I use
like a theme das file oh okay I see what
I did
okay this is this might work
alright let me run this by you and see
what if we take these themes and instead
of using like stylesheet create here
which normally I would definitely
recommend we just make them like
straight objects right and then we say
like basically we just put the values in
here so let me do it with addition first
just to show you what I mean and see if
if that could work
so actually any think will that work
all right yeah let me eat all right so
let's let's do this
what if we did themes so we'll have this
this themes object right within the
themes object we'll have one called
addition and then within addition we
could say like background color and we
could again we'll call it green and
let's just we'll make two just so that
we could switch and we'll make one
called
subtraction I believe subtraction was
pink okay so we have addition and
subtraction and then
[Music]
and then we can have let's say active
theme is going to be is going to equal
let's actually let's switch that up
oops
and I messed this up already background
background color there we go
I do that did not look right okay so we
have that here now in here we'll make a
let's say will say active theme is gonna
equal theme and that's what we'll put
mode right once it seemed as not to find
what's theme is the fun didn't I define
it down here
all themes okay so our active theme is
themes dot mode now in here we can say
background background color equals let's
see active theme dot
let's see background background color
right I think that'll work okay all
right let's see if that works if it
works then I'll explain more about why
it works
okay let's try subtraction now yeah and
these ones won't work right cuz we don't
have anything for them yet okay all
right so this works so basically we've
what we've done then is active theme is
equal to whatever theme name is equal to
the mode right which is addition
subtraction multiplication division
right so then we can just use active
theme in here so we don't we don't ever
have to worry about well what's the mode
down here because we've already set what
the active theme is so then down here we
could add as many different things as we
want like as many different attributes
oops not there here right and and we
will what we'll add I'm sure we'll add
different colors for various things but
then that way that gives us a really
easy way to switch themes so and now we
can actually get rid of a lot of a lot
of what we done let me get rid of them
up here too we had actually if I just
copy these this should work yeah let's
copy that and application nice
alright so that'll work let's do a
little bit of cleanup here
okay
cool so now we have our all our base
styles here and then we can override any
of those from here and we'll just verify
that that works everything should work
awesome cool so now we have colors maybe
not the the prettiest of colors but for
a target audience for kids this this
might actually be fun right I don't
really know maybe I'll have to look at
some color theory for children if I
before like we really decide on what the
colors should be but for now this this
is okay probably the only other thing
that I'd want to do right now is change
the colors of like the enemies maybe in
terms of usability I guess like the most
pressing thing would be SB this needs to
be wider so let's make that wider so
that the entire thing is visible I don't
know what it is right now let's see so
that's our picker and I don't think we
have any styles for that yet okay so we
do we have a width set to 100 let's see
if like 150 would work I think 150 or
work see how that looks
yeah for sure that works it looks a
little awkward but at least that fits
for all of them also it looks like a
little bit tall I mean I want the inputs
to be nice and big so that it's easy for
kids to use like a touchscreen but I
think we can maybe go with like 40 for
the height and see how that looks
oops didn't mean to hit that key okay
all right there we go 40 looks better
all right that's good and I do have this
Texas battle math text let's give this a
style style equals sorry about my typing
that I just I only use this keyboard
pretty much when I do these streams
twice a week and sometimes not even then
so it's totally different from like the
normal MacBook ebook that I use keyboard
that I use so definitely messes up my
typing let's just call this title so
lifestyles lot title we want our title
to be bigger so we're gonna put this
just in our normal styles so we want
font size to be let's try 24 pixels and
see how that looks and then what to
figure out like what kind of font family
we want to
font-family let's go Comic Sans I wonder
if that's like if that's it we'll work
by default nope
failing to compile what did I do
oops I didn't put a comma let's just
have fun willful Comic Sans in there no
Comic Sans usually awful oh no it won't
work
yeah I'll maybe I have to look up what
it is let's see there we go
web safe fonts ok comic sans ms ok so
let's try that actually while we're here
let's just see if there's another one
that I like better let's go with this I
just want something that looks like you
know kid kid-friendly right I don't
really want to go with Comic Sans like
as my final solution here oops
I'm just gonna use backticks that way
this won't matter I could have used
single quotes too but my hands just hit
the back take first there we go okay so
here's our our Comic Sans I definitely
want a little bit more padding between
the top of this and the bottom of that
no notice let's see I don't know that
still looks really like large what is my
my zooming in on this
I am Wow
okay for some reason I was super zoomed
in on this so now this makes a lot more
sense as to what everything looked huge
so let me let me check my zoom level
alright so this is the real level of
zoom alright I think we have some work
to do because now this is a totally
different story
alright so we got seven minutes let's
try to increase a lot of of what we've
been doing here
okay I would like to take this these
styles for the picker and move them down
and so let's copy these well actually
cut them and go say styles dot picker
okay and I'm gonna switch this so that
it's actually whoops let's make it 60
and let's make the title 32 and let's
make these
okay let's let's do this let's make
let's make a character style and that's
what we'll put our width and height so
that way we don't have to change them
both all the time and I'm gonna switch
them up and let's give them double
but width and height that they have
right now see how that looks
and then the math text mm-hm
alright let's let's try that out with 26
maybe let's bump that up to 28 for now I
know it's not a lot but we'll see how it
looks we also need to add on our hero
and enemies we have with those here we
are styles that hero so we'll add here
is styles dot character
and we'll do the same thing for our
enemies all right now let's let's see
what that looks like okay not bad I may
make things a little bit bigger
hmm
that's weird it's not it's not letting
me change this area
now we have all this space
interesting okay we have about three
minutes left before we go to the
questions if anybody has any suggestions
now that I finally realized that I had
the zoomed in a lot um let me know I'm
thinking I could definitely do with some
more padding like top and bottom padding
let's see so we could do padding
vertical and say something like just you
like sixteen pixels for now sixteen
units react native is basically unitless
okay it just felt a little tight up here
and down here
and we do have like so we're using
flexbox so like right now this container
is supposed to take up all the space
that's left left over after this
container in this container do their
things so what I could do is maybe make
this container bigger don't not have
this in an actual container interesting
okay yeah so let's say we come up to
like here and I can have this stuff come
up here it just seems too far down right
now you know I would kind of like to
have better-looking the Pickers okay
maybe it would like to have better
looking input so I don't want to look
into that as well to see like maybe
there's better styled inputs that we
could bring in
all right what do you think let me know
Humberto says just think if this was for
Atari you would be almost completely
done actually that would be kind of cool
what if what if we made a like a react
native plugin that lets you have Atari
as a target like you could design it in
with react native but it compiled down
to be able to play on an Atari that
would actually that would be really cool
I have no idea what it would take but
there's a guy I work with that that used
to write programs for the Atari I don't
know if he still does but he would know
what it would take to do that all right
so let me I don't really have enough
time left on my appointment over timer
to do anything so let's just go right to
the questions here I'm gonna scroll up
to where we left off actually let me let
me commit this stuff okay let's do a git
commit a.m. so we're gonna whoops we're
gonna add and commit at the same time
and let's say we're adding a new feature
and we'll say we add themes
for each mode okay we didn't have full
themes but I mean that's basically what
we did so let's commit that and push it
okay since it's just me working on this
right now and it's a small like side
project I'm committing straight to
master normally if you were working on
like open source or a project with the
team you would want to do every change
on a separate branch and then submit a
pull request but for your own projects I
mean it's fine to do it like this once
you actually launch you probably don't
want to have like your master branch the
one you work on all the time you want to
work on maybe a dev branch alright
Ludo Muir says hey why did you choose
react / UJS in one sentence one sentence
I know react but I don't know view if
you want a better explanation than that
let me know alright pub ji skilled okay
I think I think there's a conversation
going on between people in the chat so
I'm gonna skip through some of those
Luke Lucas says view or react I've heard
good things about you but I've never
used it I work with react all the time
so that's definitely my my go-to if I
need to build something but I have
nothing against for you
okay there's a question about where did
this program where you where is the
execute this program I'm not sure what
you're asking but it looks like rabbit
works was trying to answer and say it's
a react native app so native mobile app
or web the inside that app so yeah when
we do go mobile it won't be a webview
where it will actually like make it real
native native app so we could also use
electron or something like electron to
make it a desktop app so right now what
I'm thinking is web app will be first
and then will work on Android and iOS
and we might do electron just to give an
example of how to do electron I just
don't really see like considering the
target audience I think they're way more
likely to access it unlike their parents
phones as an app or on on a computer
just as a website but I mean I could see
like maybe some parents aren't
comfortable letting their children on
the web unsupervised which is definitely
a bad idea
so like potentially if they didn't have
a lot of time to supervise they could
just like turn off the internet but if
they had downloaded the desktop app
version it would still work so I think
there's uh just probably value in that
like see there's a way to do windows 10
apps - now from react native so we might
try that because I'm interested to see
how that works I've never I've never
seen it done yet and I've never done it
so that's another option Julian says the
yellow kind of hurts my eyes yeah it
yeah definitely not set on these colors
yet no face says it looks terrible again
yeah they were just whenever colors I
thought of while I was typing it out
Rex on mas says I'm doing Android
development now which keyboard do you
normally are I'm sorry I struggle with
those tags and attributes yeah I guess
I'm not sure if you're talking about the
like the JSX syntax and stuff like that
yeah if you're not used to that then I
could I could definitely see is that
being a little difficult dark-dark
Connie's I'm not sure how to pronounce
that says which keyboard do you normally
use the MacBook one yes I normally just
use the so I have two Mac books my work
is like a brand-new MacBook Pro and then
I have a 2015 MacBook Pro that's my
personal one so I use those keyboards
most they are a little different but
they're they're similar enough that
there's usually not too much of a
difference but then like for my PC I
have this keyboard which like the the
distance that you have to travel like to
click a key is significantly more than
on like the very low profile MacBook Pro
keyboards so it kind of messes me up and
then like the there's all these
differences between the desktop and the
Mac keyboard that it's just like extra
stuff that I have to think about that
kind of throws me off so I'm kind of
thinking about getting a different
keyboard anyway this is just the one
that came with my computer but I I'm in
the process of buying a house I'm gonna
move since I don't want to buy anything
now because I'll just have to pack it up
and move it and within the next month so
maybe maybe after I get all moved in and
stuff I could think about getting a new
keyboard that may be more kind of
comfortable
Rex on mosses is this recap where we
recapping I guess no now and it looks
like Rex on Wallace was pretty bored
because I got a little sleeping emoji
and a walking emoji so I guess that
meant it was boring so they are walking
away so apologies for that Rex on or
Rexy on maybe next time it'll be a
little bit less less boring for you
all right so Edwin asks OVS code over
sublime why I don't know if it's still
like this but the last time I check
sublime code cost money is that true
maybe I'm mistaken and visual studio
code is free and also I might be
mistaken but sublime I thought was a Mac
only program but vs code is
cross-platform so those are my main
reasons for using the yes code instead
of sublime if I'm mistaken about those
though please let me know I probably
won't switch because I'm used to this
but for somebody just starting out
trying to figure out sublime might be a
good option as well do you have some
video about Python no I don't have any
videos about Python but there are
probably Python videos on this channel
on the free code camp YouTube channel
Edwin says thanks for doing this by the
way you're welcome thanks for watching
DPI gaming says what game are you making
it's a game called battle math i I
played it I played it on a whiteboard
with my son when he was first learning
math problems and so I'm trying to make
a an actual like computer game version
of it so it's just
a game where you play you do math
problems if you get them right you
defeat an enemy if you get them wrong
more enemies show up DPI gaming says
show please alright let me go over to to
the actual game so here's here's the
game and I'm gonna zoom in again I need
to remember to zoom back out but so
here's the game you type your answer
here you can change the mode right so
pretty pretty straightforward for now
definitely am interested in having
better graphics and themes here
Abdullah says what's your name my name
is Jesse VAR I'd div do voli sorry if
I'm mispronouncing your name let me know
it's supposed to be pronounced says the
Corsair mechanical keyboards are nice
you know what I've tried those out in a
store and I did really liked them so
they're on my list of potential
keyboards Kim perks says I have to go
thank you for this video I'll be
watching the next one Oh awesome
thanks for watching
I have a question have you ever gone to
a server farm in person I have not but
that would be cool to see Abdullah says
where are you from and where are you
shifting to where are you moving to I'm
originally from West Virginia in the
United States I live in Ohio right now
and I'm gonna stay in Ohio so I'm gonna
stay in the same city of sue in Vallejo
I'm just moving right now I'm kind of
like outside the city limit so I'm gonna
move like closer into town basically
it's just a bigger house when I bought
this house only had one kid and it was
perfect now I have four kids and they're
getting bigger and it's kind of tight it
just seems like there's not a lot of
space for anything so this would be a
bigger house right
now I'm just in the corner of a basement
with tablecloths hanging instead of
walls so I should be able to make like a
proper office there for a while just be
in a basement but eventually I'd like to
get walls put up and everything and so
should be it should be nice for the for
the family no face says sublime has bugs
I use atom no face says sublime text I
used on Windows ok and Sava says sublime
is ok aunt Simone ok so evidently I am
totally mistaken and sublime is
available on Windows and Linux was it
not at one time or am I just completely
off here jubail Rollo says I use notepad
plus plus vs code and atom atom is slow
but I try to avoid make soft now that
they bought github yeah I am I used to
use atom a lot and I did notice that
atom is slower than then vs code other
than that I love Adam jr. says I used to
blind with Windows 7 and with JavaScript
enhancement plug-in it's cool like IDE
sublime lambo of environment ok so
evidently sublime is is better than I
thought so apologies maybe some sublime
is is definitely more versatile ok var
do volley says West Virginia is
beautiful yeah it is for sure
if you don't know about West Virginia
it's one of the poorest states in the
United States but it's also one of the
most beautiful over 70% of the land area
is is forest so there's a lot of great
like mountains trees like rivers and
streams people go whitewater rafting and
skiing and great if you are really
into the outdoors and camping and hiking
awesome state for that if you're really
into like big cities and things like
that it's not a good place for you none
of the cities here are big
we have no professional sports teams so
like it's it's definitely different than
a lot of the other states but it does
get made fun of because we're very poor
Schmitt State so it's it gets made fun
of a lot but it's definitely beautiful
Michael Carillo said you're doing this
hope you get your new job doing doing
what sorry Michael I'm not sure what
you're referring to so do it doing what
I hope you get your new job viruses I
started using sublime and Linux
environment around 2014 ish Wow all
right evidently I have no idea what I'm
talking about in regard to sublime so
I'm I definitely apply how did I not
know this
jason says probably the last place to be
touched by cyberpunk oh yeah if you're
referring to West Virginia then yeah I'd
say so
West Virginia is like if like everything
goes like terrible right and like
there's some type of apocalypse when the
cities are destroyed like West Virginia
is the place that will change the least
right people will probably be living in
the hills of West Virginia and their
life will barely change right so it's
not that's kind of life's not for
everybody but if you enter that it's
it's a great place for it
Savva says vs code is awesome I don't
know why people wouldn't use it yeah I
really like vs code but I mean there are
really good options out there so it's
definitely not the only or maybe you're
not the best option
oh Michael says they're doing the live
streams and helping other people yeah
doing the live streams and like the
conference talks and stuff was huge for
me trying to find a job so I like a
couple months ago I had a big job search
and went on a bunch of interviews and if
you're interested in that check out my
youtube channel I have a couple of
videos about it the links in the in the
description in this video I go over a
lot of what what happened and what
helped and what didn't help in my job
search but yeah definitely I got asked
in my interviews a lot about about this
I actually speak into that I'm gonna
have to end this stream in just a minute
here and do my job
let's see I just a few more questions my
voice is starting to go too
michael says let me introduce you to my
Mississippi yeah I guess Mississippi is
probably pretty comparable to West
Virginia it's a little warmer in
Mississippi but in terms of like
economic status and stuff it's
comparable oh wow Phoenix says the free
code camp watermark is over your faith
can you change the frame position I
never knew that is it is it like that
for everybody let me know I mean yeah I
can definitely change it
SM mqq says I'm a beginner how or how do
I start go to free code camp org and
sign up there and do their free lessons
that's a great place to start
Jayson Lima says boot camp or computer
science degree if you could pick one if
I had a scholarship and I could go to
school for free or for very inexpensive
and not have to take out loans I would
do a CS degree like assuming I didn't
let's say like I didn't have a family or
anything like it was just on my own then
I do CS degree if I had to pay fully for
that school forget it I'd never I'd
never get a regular degree and I would
go with the boot camp the loans are just
so so crazy okay
Michael Carillo says okay so the
watermark is on the YouTube site but not
on the Roku app okay
alright I'm gonna have to finish up here
because I got a log into my work
computer and get started at my software
engineering job but it was awesome
talking with you all I think we had a
really good QA we got some really nice
ugly themes go on here so well we'll fix
that if you all have suggestions for
themes you know definitely send them my
way otherwise you know hopefully I'll
get some inspiration for themes before
Friday the next stream so I hope to do
another stream Friday morning and if you
can make it there it'll probably be at
the same time at 8 a.m. Eastern Time
thanks again so much for watching and
until next time have a great day